I hope it works and yeah thank you all
for being here as Pedro said Ellen made
the best introduction for our talk
already so whoever was at the talk just
before you already know what is going to
come we are both members of data science
for social good thank you okay
yeah better okay we both Lisa and I are
both members for for data science for
social good
it's an organization based in Berlin or
by data science for social good Berlin
is based in Berlin and we try to help
organizations and especially nonprofits
with help we help them with data science
actually so we help them with their
problems when it comes to data questions
process challenges questions about
effectiveness of their impact oh yeah
actually I wanted to introduce Lisa a
bit more she's working so we are both
data scientists ourselves as at a
professional level so Lisa I was working
at Dai metrics Consulting Group in
Stuttgart and I'm working for better
place a non-profit here in Berlin yeah
and in our spare time we do data science
for social good let's have a look look
at the agenda first who are we who is
data science for social good Berlin what
nonprofits we work with and we worked
already with what are most common
problems that a lot of nonprofits in
Berlin face and what projects did we do
already and leases then go and is
talking you through one of the projects
that we did in our last data phone this
year
[Music]
data science for social good Berlin at
the moment has 15 organizers so Ellen is
one of the organizers
I see cut here as well and Lisa and
myself and we run the organization so
it's not very data science II what we
are doing we really run the nonprofit
and we have far more than 100 volunteers
already that help us with their
expertise with their experience in data
science if you have any anymore or
interest in more details have a look at
our website and or just contact us by
phone or by email have a look online at
various blocks that members of us write
[Music]
our working structure as you can imagine
we are all data scientists also in the
inner organizational team so our work is
very structured especially compared to
other nonprofits we used to work with so
their organizers we do the onboarding of
nonprofits the onboarding of other
volunteers the project on-boarding and
off-boarding as well the management of
these various projects that we run we
run or we organize events especially the
data phone that we talk about a bit
later we do marketing and communication
so we just do everything that needs to
be done to run a non-profit the general
organization documentation whatever is
needed also legal stuff that is just
needed to run a non-profit so who do we
work with so we try to help as many
nonprofits mainly in the Berlin area as
possible there is one big limitation and
you can probably guess what it is we
really want to help nonprofits but that
nonprofits needs to have any data we can
work with and you might be surprised a
lot of nonprofits don't have enough data
or not the relevant data to actually
solve their problems or let us solve
their problems and as I said and
sometimes we have to tell them come back
in two years use the time collect some
data
all the data in a meaningful way and
come back in one or two years and then
we are able to help you what kind of
problems do nonprofits face what do you
think what is what are the biggest
challenges questions they have any ideas
[Music]
nothing okay so I think so a big a big
question or a big challenge a lot of
especially smaller nonprofits have is
they have quite high demands or quite
high costs compared to what they get for
it so especially the marketing costs or
the personal costs compared to the
donations they are able to get that is
one of the requests we quite often get
another one is unstructured data and
also a lot of nonprofits want to know
how effective they are and how they can
actually measure their activity
effectiveness so what we can do and what
we did already is we can do donor
segmentation we can do target group
analysis we can help especially in the
unstructured data area we can help with
define processes of how to structure and
how to automate data processes I mean
what you actually probably do on a day
to day basis
[Music]
one of the or definitely our most
prominent events every year almost every
year is the data phone we run it we try
to run it every year so far with it for
and in total we were able to help nine
nonprofits to solve very specific
questions or challenges they had and one
of the one of the last or one project
from the last data fund that was a mess
to do known occurrences of studies
Without Borders and we helped them to
explore and to deep dive into their
survey survey
results so they collect survey results
on a regular basis and he wanted they
wanted to get more out of it they wanted
to do more analysis with those survey
results a data phone is a weekend so it
starts on Friday someone after lunch and
ends on Sunday and it's really it's a
weekend full of hacking programming
coding but also a lot of community
building getting to know each other
helping each other learning from each
other having fun it's a big part of it
and yeah I'm now handing over to Lisa
she's going to explain in more detail
about that one project that that we did
on our last date a phone thank you thank
you thank you I am I will continue I
first of all I will talk you and through
at the general process of a data phone
at DSS to Berlin and of course obviously
before such an event can happen there
has to be some planning and some
preparation so first of all we need to
kind of prepare the projects that the
volunteer is kind of approached at the
data zone and preparing the project
means that when an NGO reaches out to us
and they say well we do have a problem
and we think maybe a data science is a
way to solve it can you help us then we
first we have to meet the NGO and we
have to sit down together and talk about
their actual problem and to find out is
it really a problem that we can approach
with data science and that our
volunteers can solve and we need to find
out as a problem it's realist they do
the data at the NGO do they have the
necessary data is the quality sufficient
but also is the project that we would
define time wise and something that's
realistic for data on because we only
have weekend and then we talk with the
NGO we find out whether the project is
realistic and we can say yes let's make
it a data a fun project and then
afterwards we we go to our volunteers
and we have to find data and
we are looking for data ambassadors
these are volunteers that want to get
involved maybe a little bit more and
they they sign up for working closer
together with the NGO and they prepared
a project so they meet and they decide
well what's the goal what should the
impact be what or how does the data have
to be prepared and then the data
ambassadors they start preparing the
data and they are something like the
contact person for the NGO when it comes
to preparing the project because for us
it is to Berlin there are other things
keeping us busy before the data's on we
obviously have to connect organize the
events so we are looking for a location
we need to find sponsors we need to find
volunteers we need to get all the
logistic stuff and make it work and yeah
so when we have like the preparation
then then the actual data thing can
happen and what you see here is a little
schedule about what it looks like when
the weekend is happening so and it
starts on Friday afternoon in general
and there's a reception and then the
NGOs they present the projects so they
come and they talk to the volunteers
about their projects and what's going on
and then the volunteers can decide
afterwards what sounds most interesting
to them where do they want to get
engaged and then they can inform they
form groups and during Saturday and
Sunday mornings they were they work on
the projects and analyze the data and
then on Sunday afternoon that's I think
almost at the best part of today that's
one weekend there's the final
presentation so the volunteers they show
and the results to the NGOs and also to
the other one and here's the other
groups and you can really see amazing
things well yeah what the volunteers
actually are able to do in such a short
time and that's pretty cool to see and
yes if I said I will tell you a little
bit more about the project with studia
Nonna cleansin it's a nonprofit
organization that Awards scholarships to
students and countries with social and
economic issues
and thereby the support to students but
they also try to improve the local
infrastructure or the education
infrastructure in the countries and we
work together with studio non the
constant willin and they support
students and the Democratic Republic of
Congo and what you can see here is like
a project agreement that we have with
the NGO before the data huh and that's
something our data ambassadors and we
work out together with the NGO before
and first of all when we define or we
define a goal and we define the impact
that the project should have which is
really important to be really clear
because this is one thing that helps the
volunteers when they start working on
their projects to really think about
where could analysis go what kind of
ideas
should we yeah where should we start
working and what should analysis look
like or what models should we build
whatever they want to do and how should
the problem be approached and in the
case of studio only Kansan as Eva has
already said they have survey data and
they wanted on the volunteers to explore
the survey data and to find common
topics or correlations to then in the
end make some suggestions or
recommendations how to program itself
can be improved and the impact should be
that they check their theory of change
against the reality if it's working what
they actually doing and then one thing
that's also really important or maybe
most important of course is when we
prepare the projects or anything about
data on projects what kind of data can
be used or what data is available and
that's also really important for us to
be clear and precise here before the
broad site to find out what data is
there and how should they look like
because as many of you I think are data
scientists and we all know that the
quality of the data that you work with
is so crucial for the success of a
project
so here's 2dn only concern for example
they had survey data from their students
and the Republic of Congo and it's a
french-speaking country so just the
answers and responses around French but
we here in Berlin
our Balan tears most of them they don't
speak French so we needed to have the
data in English and then for example a
NGO committed themselves to translate
responses and then also to provide the
responses in yeah I think it was in
Google sheets so that our volunteers
could work with it then here well it's
called the process versus more a list of
what we kind of like commit ourselves a
CSS G to provide but also the data
ambassadors and the NGO so we say we
organize the event we find volunteers
that are willing to help out and work
for the project then the data
ambassadors they prepare the project
they do some data cleaning and
preparation beforehand and they also
commit themselves to be present during
the data's on the weekend so that they
can guide the volunteers and they have
some ideas of the group itself is not so
creative and doesn't know what to do
then they are there to help them out and
the NGO itself is also what they commit
himself to is to kind of provide the
necessary data and then also support the
data ambassadors and the volunteers as
well before the project but and also
during the projects during the data thon
they're there and they are present the
whole time and work together with the
volunteers on the project so here's a
little bit about how I'm the project
data itself looked like we have already
said they had what I wanted us to
analyze survey data so it was three
years that they have collected surveys
or they asked their participants to fill
out the surveys and you can see it there
are not so many participants maybe so
it's not a huge amount of data but you
can see there are different questions
every year different a different number
of questions and different data types
was maybe not so easy to incomparable
the volunteers did during the data thon
they first they clean the data and
prepared it but then they did maybe some
rather basic statistics in the beginning
so they counted just responses and
analyzed that and
visualize it so that the NGO could
actually benefit from nice visualization
and then they also tried to identify
some trends over a year and I think they
also did some language processing to
analyze the free text data that they had
any question ears and here you can see
at least some numbers or I wanted to
show you a little bit how the final
presentations looked like and what the
NGO got out of the project because of
course they wanted to get insights about
what how they could improve their
program but also what they got we're
like insights about possible weaknesses
of their questionnaires and how they
could improve their questionnaires and
then in a case what do you see here just
as an example I'm studyin only Canton um
when the student gets a scholarship the
student also kind of like has to come
lead a project and has to implement a
project you to get or to continue with
the scholarship but the student only
concern realized that some of the
students they struggle completing their
projects and then they asked in the
survey what are possible risk factors
like what do you rate as a risk sector
I'm - not completing the project and
then here you can see the different
factors that they had to rate and then
it came out that financial risks or
financial problems are a really high
risk for the students not to complete
the project successfully and here the
network it also it's an analysis of the
free text data and you can also see like
the big note I'm not sure whether you
can read it but it says hidden ceiling
so also it's a lot about financial
problems and this was yeah a really
interesting insight for the NGO where
they can now continue to work on how
they can support their students and yeah
I think for NGO it's actually really
beneficial to get the insights to see
okay what's in their data and then to
know how to improve their program but
another thing that's actually really
important for us is the SST during such
a data home project or what makes a data
fun project successful for us it's not
only the insights
at the NGO get after the analysis but
also that during the whole weekend the
the volunteers and the NGO people there
is a together they work together and we
get feedback from the NGO people that
they say well during the weekend we see
like we get to meet data scientists and
we get to know how they think like they
see the data and it's a completely
different approach how they think about
data how they work with the data and
what things you can do with data and for
Isis data experts it's kind of like
obvious when we see data and you know
from the beginning on what you want to
do what you want to Anna to analyze but
from an NGO perspective when people are
not really interested in data add or
maybe it's sometimes scary when they see
numbers and stuff like that and they
don't know what to do
but during said to week and they kind of
like realize well there's so much power
in the data we have and it's so it can
be so useful for us we should think
about how can we use it in the future as
well and that's something we really love
to see when the people from the end
nonprofits start thinking about their
data like that because that's actually
where we want them to get to and I think
that's almost the end of our
presentation but the first of all we
want to thank you for for coming and for
being here and especially for being
interested in the topic because it's
something we are really passionate about
and seeing many people here who are
interested in data science for social
good is really cool to see and yeah if
you're interested enough that you say
well we also would like to do a data
science for good then we have an
opportunity for you so I mean we are
here also to to get so many volunteers
or find people who are interested and if
you think that's something for you we
would like to to you volunteer for a
data science for social good as well
then you have the possibility to to be
added to our volunteer list so we have
here list you can just drop us an email
at volunteer at the SSG - Berlin and
then we'll add you to the list and
whenever they are interesting projects
coming up or when there is a data thon
happening then we just write an email
and you get to know what kind of
projects out there and then you can
decide whether sounds interesting and
you can sign up for it or well you say
no this is not the thing for me and then
but maybe the next project would be
would be okay and maybe if you say that
you're even interested in volunteering a
little bit more then you could also
think about like joining as a CSS to
Berlin we are always looking for helping
hands also in our organizers team
because running an organization is a lot
of work so if you're interesting you can
also traverse an email or you could just
come to us after the talk and then we
can have a chat and yeah I think that's
it so there would be a time for a Q&A
session
[Music]
okay some time for questions yes sorry
hi thank you for the talk I'm interested
in whether or not you experience any
problems with gaps in understanding not
only misunderstandings from the
nonprofit side about data and data
science but also perhaps more
interestingly misunderstandings from
data scientists about social
organizations and the structure and what
they're looking for and how do you
bridge those if they have them yeah yeah
thank you for the question
I think I mean not at not at the data's
on but what comes in my mind is one of
our other events that that that we run
on a regular basis we face that quite
often that especially the NGO is so deep
it's so closed into their problems and
into their world that it's quite
difficult for for data analysts from
outside or from data scientists to
actually grasp the problem in a short
time and I think for us so one of the
challenges that we want to get better as
well and that we where we need the
preparation and the data ambassadors for
the big event is really to make sure
that the problem is also the right
problem for for a data phone for example
or also for any of the other events that
we are running and so that problem can't
be too complex because the problem can
be complex but it has to be easy to
explain so that the the volunteers don't
don't waste their time in in asking the
questions just to understand the problem
so yeah we faced that a lot yeah hi
Percy thank you for the talk I actually
I I'm a bit of an impostor I'm actually
a developer but I came because I would
like to work with social impact and
especially with with environmental
causes I'm sorry I was wondering this
this DSG looks great for data science
but do you also know if there's like a
developers for social good in Berlin or
anywhere or I can stop
I don't mind I I don't know actually but
to be fair I think you should still sign
up with data science for social good
because some of the issues we have needs
some developing and they need
programming and coding and depending on
what you burn for and what you want to
work for it might be just writing for
you anyway
so please okay thank you yeah we'll do
that thank you thank you for the talk I
was also wondering so you were
mentioning there the hackathons in
Berlin but is that also possible to do
this kind of remotely or like if you
can't easily go to Berlin or like how
often would the hackathons be in Berlin
and is it possible to do it from like
home office kind of thing what once a
year in Berlin it's only okay so
hackathons are only in Berlin but for
example like I'm living in stupid and
working there so I just work remotely
for DSS to Berlin we have like a call or
meeting every second week so I just
participate via a video call so that's
possible and then for the hackathon I
come to Berlin or for now for the
conference but I guess it depends on how
shows you want to work with them or how
often you want to travel to Berlin as
well that you could yeah but it's still
possible if you want to yeah I slept two
questions are all your projects done
through hackathons or do you have any
that go on over a longer period and the
second question is have you had any
contact with larger NGOs because I'd
imagine they might have more data or is
it just they're too complex to work with
okay so a first the second question we
we said we like to work with NGOs where
we can have a real impact and we say
that the large NGOs they should have
they have more money so they could kind
of like a data scientist to work for
them and that's why if we have the
choice we prefer to work with the
smaller NGOs because they just don't
have enough money to pay a data
scientist but in general we would work
with bigger and Chios as well and as you
said they might have more data that's
kind of like true and Western ok no we
are just working with the hackathon so
I'm really a small projects more very
precise and you can like finish after a
few hours or and a few hours but I think
there are other organizations who are
kind of like helping NGOs if they have
longer projects and so there are other
organizations that do similar work than
we do yeah maybe to add to that not
every project has to go or goes to the
data phone I think that was part of your
question as well so sometimes we we face
questions that are quite easy for us to
answer or that we can just answer in one
evening so we have other event formats
as well that don't have that huge
preparation time and don't have that
huge set up of a data phone so yeah
that's no more questions ok so we are
done for today
I hope you all reach out the designs for
social with Berlin once you start
helping people and using your skillset
and towards that it's amazing and it's
really hard to stop so applause for our
speakers and thank you